>>> GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON.
TONIGHT, WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME
IN THE SHOW NIGHT AFTER NIGHT
TRYING TO EXPLAIN WHAT’S
HAPPENING TO OUR COUNTRY.
IT’S DEPRESSING A LOT OF THE
TIME BECAUSE THE ANSWER IS
ALWAYS THE SAME.
AMERICA IS NOT ROTTEN.
IT’S A GREAT PLACE.
THE PEOPLE THAT RUN IT ARE
ROTTEN.
YOU HAVE BEEN BETRAYED BY THE
PEOPLE THAT LEAD YOU.
THAT’S WHY THINGS ARE SO
VOLATILE.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT A CRISIS OF
OUR INSTITUTIONS.
THEY ARE CORRUPT, SOME
COLLAPSING.
WE SAY THAT A LOT BECAUSE IT IS
TRUE.
WE SHOULD BE MORE PRECISE.
NOT ALL OF OUR INSTITUTIONS ARE
THE SAME.
SOME ARE BAD, SOME ARE AWFUL.
LOOMING ABOVE THE REST IS THE
WORST OF ALL, THE NEWS MEDIA.
THEY ARE THE MOST CORRUPT.
HOW CORRUPT IS THE NEWS MEDIA?
IMAGINE A DRUNKEN TEENAGE BORDER
GUARD AT THE CROSSING BETWEEN
TOGO AND BER KEY NA FAW SA
SHAKING YOU DOWN AT MIDNIGHT.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS MUCH
MORE CORRUPT THAN THAT.
THE MEDIA ARE MORE CROOKED THAN
JIMMY HOFFA WAS.
THEY ARE MORE DISHONEST THAN
YOUR AVERAGE BRIBE-TAKING
BUILDER IN QUEENS, MORE
TREACHEROUS THAN THE MAFIA.
YOU WILL GET A FAIRER TREATMENT
FROM AN INNER CITY DMV THAN CNN.
WORDS CAN BARELY EXPRESS THE
TRUTH OF IT.
WATCHING THE NEWS ON TELEVISION
MAKES YOU QUESTION THE SYSTEM
ITSELF.
IN WHAT VERSION OF MAYOR TOK
RACY COULD CHUCK TODD GET RICH
AND FAMOUS?
DUMB AND CONVENTIONAL NOW PASSES
AS IMPRESSIVE.
IT IS INSULTING.
WE HAVE DECIDED TO PAUSE AND
LOOK AT IT A DIFFERENT WAY.
YES, THE NEWS MEDIA ARE
PROFOUNDLY DISHONEST.
ALL OF US LIE FROM TIME TO TIME.
THAT’S THE HUMAN CONDITION.
IMAGINE IF LYING WAS YOUR JOB.
IMAGINE FORCING YOURSELF TO TELL
LIES ALL DAY ABOUT EVERYTHING IN
WAYS THAT WERE SO TRANSPARENT
AND SO OUTLANDISH THAT THERE IS
NO WAY THE PEOPLE LISTENING TO
YOU COULD POSSIBLY BELIEVE
ANYTHING YOU SAID.
THEN, IMAGINE DOING THAT AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN EVERY DAY OF
YOUR PROFESSIONAL LIFE FOR YOUR
ENTIRE LIFE?
COULD YOU DO THAT?
IF YOU COULD, CNN HAS AN OPENING
ON THE MEDIA ANALYSIS DESK.
IF YOU ARE A NONSOCIOPATH THICK,
NORMAL PERSON, YOUR ANSWER IS
YOU COULD NOT DO THAT, NEVER LIE
LIKE THAT.
YOU HAVE TO RESPECT THE PEOPLE
THAT CAN.
THEY ARE LIKE OLYMPIANS IN
REVERSE.
THEY ACHIEVE FEATS SO
DISHONORABLE THAT YOU GAST IN
HORROR AS YOU WATCH THEM.
AT THE SAME TIME, YOU HAVE TO
RESPECT THOSE SKILLS.
TAKE A LOOK AT THESE GOLD
MEDALISTS IN DUE POLICETY AND
ASK YOURSELF IF YOU COULD SAY
SOMETHING LIKE THIS WITH A
COMPLETELY STRAIGHT FACE ABOUT
KAMALA HARRIS.
>> SHE IS INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL
AND DOES EVERYTHING
PROFESSIONALLY WITH THE UTMOST
INTEGRITY.
>> KAMALA HARRIS IS INDEPENDENT,
SUCCESSFUL, STRONG, ALSO A
DEVOTED WIFE AND SHE IS NOT
ASHAMED OF THAT.
>> I WOULD SAY HER PERFORMANCE
AS A RUNNING MATE WAS FLAWLESS.
OTHER THAN BARACK OBAMA, IN MY
CAREER, I HAVE NOT SEEN ANYBODY
THAT CAME IN WITH THAT KIND OF
RAW MATERIAL IN THAT SHE FITS
THE MOMENT IN SUCH A POWERFUL
WAY.
>> SHE IS WHAT EVERY WORKING
WOMAN STRIVES TO BE.
>> OF COURSE, SHE IS FLAWLESS.
KAMALA HARRIS IS EVERYTHING
WOMEN WANT TO BE, FALSE, HOLLOW,
CUNNING, CONSUMED WITH POLITICAL
POWER, REALLY A MODEL FOR YOUR
DAUGHTERS.
MAKE THAT WOMAN VICE-PRESIDENT.
SO THEY DID.
ON THE NIGHT THEY DID, THEY
CELEBRATED.
IN FACT, CELEBRATION MIGHT BE
TOO MILD A WORD.
WHAT HAPPENED ON CABLE
TELEVISION THAT NIGHT IS
TYPICALLY AND BY LAW IN A LOT OF
PLACES CONFINED TO BEDROOMS AND
OTHER PRIVATE SPACES.
THAT NIGHT, THEY DID IT IN
PUBLIC.
THEY WERE PROUD OF IT.
IT WAS PRIME TIME OVER ON CNN.
>> HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
>> AHH.
IT’S -- I ALMOST CAN’T TALK
RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE OF THE
EMOTION.
>> EVERY ONE IS WELCOME UNDER
THIS TENT.
WE DON’T CARE WHO YOU ARE.
WE DON’T CARE IF YOU VOTED FOR
US OR NOT.
YOU’RE ALL PART OF THIS AMERICAN
EXPERIMENT.
IT WAS -- I WAS SO OVERWHELMED
TO HEAR THAT.
I DON’T CARE WHAT PEOPLE THINK,
IF THEY THINK I AM BIASSED OR
NOT.
I DON’T CARE.
I’M VERY EMOTIONAL.
WHEN YOU ASK ME HOW I’M FEELING
RIGHT NOW, I’M SORRY, THAT’S ALL
I CAN TELL YOU.
THIS IS HOW I FEEL RIGHT NOW.
I AM SO HAPPY TO HAVE THIS
PLATFORM TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS.
I MAY NOT HAVE IT AFTER THIS BUT
I REALLY DON’T CARE.
I AM SO HAPPY.
>> EVERYONE IS WELCOME UNDER
THIS TENT.
THEY ARE ALL INVITED, EXCEPT THE
WHITE SUPREMACIST AND THE Q-ANON
PEOPLE AND ANYONE ELSE THAT
DISAGREES WITH ANYTHING WE SAY.
THEY ARE ALL GOING TO JAIL.
THE REST ARE MORE THAN WELCOME
TO STAY AND OBEY OUR COMMAND.
IT WAS THAT KIND OF NIGHT,
FESTIVE, GOOD-HEARTED,
MAGNANIMOUS
MAGNANIMOUS.
MONTHS LATER, THE BIDEN FAMILY
MADE ITS VICTORIOUS PROCESSION,
THE MOOD LIFTED EVEN HIGHER.
I HAVE CHILLS, WROTE ONE EDITOR
OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
SHE WAS FEVERISH WITH JOY.
CNN LED THEIR POET TO
COMMEMORATE THE MOMENT HERE IS
THE SON ET HE WROTE.
>> THOSE LIGHTS THAT ARE
SHOOTING OUT FOR THE LINCOLN
MEMORIAL ALONG THE REFLECTING
POOL, IT IS ALMOST LIKE
EXTENSIONS OF JOE BIDEN’S ARMS
EMBRACING AMERICA.
>> NOT EVERYONE IS AS POETIC AS
DAVID CHAL YUN, THE MAN YOU JUST
SAW.
THAT’S WHY HE IS CNN’S POLITICAL
DIRECTOR.
AN ORDINARY JOURNALIST MIGHT NOT
NOTICE THAT JOE BIDEN’S ARMS ARE
LIKE TWIN BEAMS OF LIGHT
SHOOTING FORTH FROM THE
REFLECTING POOL EMBRACING
AMERICA AS A MOTHER EMBRACES A
CHILD.
AN ORDINARY JOURNALIST MIGHT
HAVE DESCRIBED HIS ARMS AS TONED
AND TAWNY AND NOT EVERYONE IS
DAVID CHALION.
THE THING ABOUT JOURNALISM, IT
IS NOT AN INDIVIDUAL
ACHIEVEMENT.
IT IS ABOUT THE GROUP.
IN JOURNALISM, IT IS THE
COLLECTIVE SPIRIT THAT MATTERS,
LIKE SYNCHRONIZED SQUIMERS OR
CERTAIN SPECIES OF INSECTS.
JOURNALISTS MOVE TOGETHER IN
CONCERT AS A HERD, IF YOU WILL.
WHEN JOE BIDEN WRITES A TALKING
POINT, THEY REPEAT IT, NOT JUST
A FEW OF THEM BUT ALL OF THEM IN
PRECISELY THE SAME WAY.
THINK OF REPORTERS AS THE NORTH
KOREAN GYMNASTIC TEAM
CELEBRATING KIM JUNE SUNG DAY IN
A SONGER STADIUM.
THEY MOVE AS ONE.
MEMBERS OF THE PRESS CORPS
ENFORM YOU THAT THIS NEW GROUP
OF POLITICIANS IN WASHINGTON IS
VERY DIFFERENT FROM ANY OTHER
GROUP OF POLITICIANS IN ALL OF
HUMAN HISTORY.
UNLIKE THE REST OF THEM, THESE
PEOPLE ARE COMMITTED TO
SOMETHING CALLED THE TRUTH.
>> PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN MAKING IT
CLEAR TO HIS ADMINISTRATION THAT
THEY WILL BE NOTHING LIKE HIS
PREDECESSOR WITH A FOCUS ON
TRUTH, SCIENCE AND TRANSPARENCY.
>> A COMMITMENT TO CLARITY,
TRANSPARENCY AND SCIENCE AND
TRUTH.
>> THE BIDEN VOWS TRUTH AND
TRANSPARENCY.
>> THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE VOWS
TRANSPARENCY AND TRUTH WHEN
SHARING INFORMATION ABOUT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WE ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT IT.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE PROMISES TO
BRING TRUTH AND SCIENCE BACK TO
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> IT IS GETTING BACK TO THE
TRUTH AND VALUING THE TRUTH.
>> GETTING BACK TO THE TRUTH,
VALUING THE TRUTH, NOW THERE IS
A REFRESHING CONCEPT.
WHO DOES THAT REMIND YOU OF, BY
THE WAY?
WE DON’T NEED PATRIARCHAL HERE.
THAT SOUNDS A LOT LIKE DAD, A
LITTLE BLUNT BUT HONEST, A
STRAIGHT-SHOOTER, SOLID,
RELIABLE, STEADY.
THAT’S JOE BIDEN.
ABOVE ALL, JOE BIDEN IS A FAMILY
MAN, TOOK THE TRAIN BACK TO
WILMINGTON EVERY NIGHT FOR THE
10,000 SQUARE FEET ESTATE A
CAMPAIGN DONOR BOUGHT FOR HIM
FOR LOBBYING.
JOE BIDEN’S FAMILY IS NORMAL,
THERE AREN’T ANY PROTRACTED SEX
SCANDALS OR ONGOING CRIMINAL
ISSUES YOU HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT.
A RECENT HEADLINE WILL TELL YOU,
JOE BIDEN WINS IN MARIO RACE
AGAINST GRANDDAUGHTER AT CAMP
DAVID, NOT SECRETLY LOBBYING FOR
CHINA OR IMPREGNATING STRIPPERS
IN ARKANSAS.
THEY ARE PLAYING MARIO LIKE YOU.
ONE MAN, ONE WOMAN, THE FIRES OF
PASSION THAT CHANGED THE COURSE
OF OUR HISTORY.
NOT SINCE ANTHONY DINED WITH
CLEOPATRA HAS A COUNTRY
WITNESSED A LOVE STORY AS MOVING
AND POIGNANT AS JILL AND JOE’S.
JILL BIDEN IS NOT JOE’S
CARETAKER.
SHE ISN’T HIS NURSE.
SHE IS HIS FULLY EQUAL ROMANTIC
PARTNER.
TOGETHER, THEY ARE LIKE TEENS
AND THE WISE HEAD OF THE NATION.
HISTORIANS AND RELATIONSHIP
EXPERTS AGREE, THE FIRST
COUPLE’S ROMANTIC GESTURES
AREN’T JUST GENUINE, THEY ARE
RESTORATIVE.
IT IS OFFICIAL, THE BIDENS
AFFECTION IS TOTALLY REAL.
IT IS IN NO WAY PART OF A SLICK
PR CAMPAIGN DEVISED BY CYNICAL
CONSULTANTS DETERMINED TO HIDE
THE PRESIDENT’S SENILITY BY
MISDIRECTION.
THE POLITICAL STORY BEGINS THIS
WAY, ON A MISSION TO REBUILD
INSTITUTIONAL NORMS AND HELP
HEAL A HURTING NATION, JOE AND
JILL BIDEN ARE TRYING SOMETHING
NOVEL AFTER FOUR YEARS OF THE
TRUMPS, A LITTLE TENDERNESS.
THAT’S RIGHT, AMERICA, A LITTLE
TENDERNESS.
THE BIDEN’S LOVE IS LIKE
MEDICINE, MORE POWERFUL THAN THE
COVID VACCINE AND YOU ONLY NEED
ONE INJECTION.
WATCH DR. JOY REID PRESCRIBE A
WHOLE LOT MORE OF IT.
>> WHAT A GREAT LOVE STORY
BETWEEN JILL BIDEN AND JOE
BIDEN.
>> IT IS A DIFFERENT KIND OF
MARRIAGE.
THIS IS A LOVE MATCH LIKE THE
OBAMAS WERE.
I THINK THAT WILL BE HEALING FOR
THE COUNTRY TOO.
>> YEAH, IT WILL BE.
THE BIDEN’S LOVE WILL BE HEALING
FOR THIS COUNTRY.
IT WILL MAKE US WHOLE AGAIN AND
IT MIGHT STOP LOOMING HYPER
INFLATION AND KEEP THE CHINESE
NAVY TO CLOSING THE SOUTH CHINA
SEA TO INTERNATIONAL SHIPPING.
WHEN YOU HAVE A LOVE LIKE THAT,
IT EMITS A MAGNETIC TUG, PEOPLE
CAN FEEL IT.
THEY SEEK YOU OUT LIKE PILGRIMS
TO BASK IN YOUR HEALING RAYS.
HERE IS THE SCENE ON THE WHITE
HOUSE LAWN JUST THIS WEEKEND AS
REPORTERS FROM ACROSS THE REGION
THREW DOWN THEIR CRUTCHES AND
APPROACHED AMERICA’S REIGNING
APOSTLE OF LOVE HOPING TO GRAZE
THE HEM OF HIS GARMENT AND BE
HEALED.
>> HOW DO YOU EXTEND THAT LOVE
STORY TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
THAT ARE FEELING SO DOWN, SO
DISCOURAGED?
>> TELL THEM THERE IS HOPE,
THERE IS HOPE.
YOU JUST HAVE TO STAY STRONG.
>> HE LIFTS YOUR SPIRITS.
>> IT IS SO DAM COLD.
>> NEXT TIME, BRING US COFFEE
TOO.
>> I WASN’T SURE YOU WOULD ALL
BE HERE.
>> WE’LL BE HERE.
>> LOVE YOUR DOGS.
>> I’LL BRING THE DOUGHNUTS NEXT
FRIDAY IF YOU COME BACK.
>> OKAY.
I’LL TELL YOU WHAT, I APOLOGIZE,
I DIDN’T EVEN HAVE ONE.
I PROMISE YOU.
>> I’M GOING TO GET IN TROUBLE.
>> I GIVE YOU MY WORD.
>> THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE IT.